the aforementioned Jeff Van Gundy former
NBA coach now analyst of course with
ESPN and ABC joining us he's got Rockets
Clippers 7:30 Eastern tonight let me
start with what McLovin just said to me
Jeff you starting your team Trey young
or Luca Dunn chick Godrich but that's
not to negate what Trey young is capable
of doing I was able to coach him on the
USA select team this summer as we
prepared for the World Cup and this guy
is a brilliant pick-and-roll player you
know he's a little under sized he can be
impacted by trapping the pick-and-roll
which I'm surprised more teams aren't
doing and defensively he still has a
ways to go but as a passer and a
pick-and-roll player
this guy he's dynamics I know we'd love
to have comparisons all the time coach
and he reminds me a little bit of what
Chris Jackson used to be when Chris
Jackson was in college that that first
year at LSU was Shaq he was unbelievable
had great handle really quick release
under sized a little bit and of course
became machmood Abdul Rauf and then we
were having this discussion could Trey
Young have been successful 25 years ago
20 years ago the way the NBA was
officiated the way you played 20 years
ago I was just yeah I mean the
undersized guards particularly the
slight guards you know they would have
they would have had they had more
trouble back then because of the hand
check because of the physicality that
was allowed and so yeah it's a different
it's a different sport now it's it's
built and you're not punished for being
smaller and the one thing that I think
Trey young has that maybe you know Chris
Jackson didn't when he was at LSU was
he's a phenomenal passer
now sometimes he doesn't you know back
at Oklahoma maybe he didn't he couldn't
pass as much because maybe he wasn't
surrounded by you know great offensive
players I didn't watch him a lot in
college but in the NBA this guy he is a
terrific passer I mean his passing
ability to me is he's great
strength and so when he makes what he'd
make eight threes last night I mean
you're impossible to guard you got the
Rockets and the Clippers let me start
with the Clippers what's your biggest
question about the Clippers so far none
zero
no questions you know if they're healthy
they're a great team I love what they've
built their you know back with the Chris
Paul trade everybody said you know they
lost the trade and now you might say
they did as well as Houston did because
montrezl harrell Lou Williams gives them
such a Patrick Beverley they have so
many components that surround Kawhi
Leonard and when Paul George gets back
Paul George I think they're a great team
I have no questions about them do you
have any concerns about load management
if you work oh if you were Doc Rivers do
you care how many games Paul George and
Kawhi Leonard play if they are healthy
yeah I think you have concerns because
you know that home court advantage
despite what everybody tells you is
important you want to have it as in many
rounds as you can they you know the more
they said obviously the harder it is
last year Toronto was an anomaly they
actually played at a higher winning
percentage without Kawhi Leonard in the
regular season than with him but Doc
Rivers knows you know that you lose your
best players for periods of time you
know you don't win as much so yeah I
think he's probably concerned but I
think they went into this with their
eyes wide open I don't think I don't
think the Clippers right now are
dictating when Kawhi Leonard says I
think you know they knew this is what he
wants to do this is how he wants to
approach his career and like any other
team they accepted that he was going to
play less but they were going to get a
great great player and I think you know
Leonard does you know he's certainly
been great and I may not like it myself
I think it's bad for the business of
basketball I think we take our consumers
far too
for granted but really when you think
about load management Dan there's very
few people who are practicing it it's
more of the star players and and then
also you know the unfortunate part is
you know everybody tells you sports
sciences preventing injuries all I see
is learn more guys being hurt now and I
wish I knew why all these injuries were
taking place when we're practicing less
when we're having less contact in
practice fewer practices or I wonder if
it's because they're not as conditioned
or not as used to the contact to be able
to withstand it I wish I knew why every
year we seem to have more and more
injuries versus less and less with all
these scientists at the forefront of
injury prevention yeah it's interesting
we're talking to Jeff Van Gundy ESPN
brings you the Clippers Rockets tonight
7:30 Eastern joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
Reggie Miller and I have been going back
and forth I said look well I don't know
I said LeBron is still a better player
than Kawhi Leonard well when I do you're
right about comparisons to me comparison
is the thief of joy you know because it
makes you choose and and whenever you
choose like dont't or a young do it
seems to diminish the other guy versus
prop up the guy you praise I always say
when you come to these things I'll give
you first pick and I'm happy with number
two it's like if you want if you want
James if I get Kawhi Leonard I'm more
than happy so I think like LeBron James
the thing that I'm most impressed this
year with Dan is a rejuvenation at the
defensive end of the floor absolutely
this guy is is playing hard and he is
leading and he's inspiring and then
obviously his vision and all that sort
of stuff is still off the charts but
it's the commitment he is
shown at the defensive end but also it's
brought his teammate around along with
Frank Vogel and I think Frank Vogel I
think we're forgetting how good a coach
he is I think what he did with Indiana
was spectacular in Orlando he wasn't
given a good team at all but now with
the Lakers I think he's showing the
touch that he has particularly at that
into the floor to get guys to play hard
I'll leave you with this because I'm
sure this will be a topic tonight and
that's James Harden and initiating
contact getting to the free-throw line
and this is historical that he's
shooting more free-throws in the first
10 games in the history of the sport
here so how do you officiate him if you
were Doc Rivers tonight looking at the
officiating on James Harden what do you
what can you point out to say give my
guys a chance here well I think
everybody needs to take a page from the
Spurs book when the Spurs guard him they
do it in such a manner to
over-exaggerate showing their hands
people get into like trying to get into
him and you know they get into his
airspace and like he's so strong he's so
adept at drawing contact initiating
contact selling contact that like I
think you first of all don't contest
this three-point shot when you have to
lunge at him yeah
he draws those shooting sighs you know
that's three to six free throws a game
right there
take those out make him make the shot
okay secondly like like San Antonio does
play with your hands out wide never ever
ever never ever reach in and try to
strip he's too strong he's too good and
that's where he gets contact I think if
you take away those type of valve you
can keep him to a manageable six to
eight free throws but it requires great
discipline particularly if he's making
shots that you don't get frustrated so I
think it starts with discipline
it starts with taking a page out of the
Spurs playbook I think that's great and
I think the whole keeping your hands
where
have your hands so he can't use your
hands against you is is really a sneaky
little tip there and you know leave it
to Popovich to figure that out yeah I
mean it's like when it's so awkward that
you play with your hands out and like up
it's like it's it's different you know
because usually you're telling your
players get your hands active you know
poke at the ball try to disrupt them but
trying to disrupt James Harden as you
said it works to his advantage because
he can use all of that to work his way
to a free throw line and you have to
make him make shots you can't take every
you can't take everything away from a
great player Dan or they wouldn't be a
great player you but you have to take
away something and I think the one thing
you have your best chance of taking away
from Harden is the free throw line if
you're disciplined I think the second
thing is that I'm surprised where teams
don't do Golden State
I had them last week against Houston
when they put out that you know they're
you know they don't have a really good
team right now
but they doubled harden on his wing
isolation more than I had seen and I
think more teams should double harden on
the wing when he's isolating
particularly late in the clock and make
other guys shoot the ball and make plays
off the dribble laughs I don't
understand why you leave the best
offensive player one-on-one sometimes
against five men to me that makes no
sense you sound like a coach why aren't
you doing that oh you know broadcasting
you can fake coach and just say yeah
that was my idea after the game you know
like they should have done this after
the game it's great can't be wrong yeah
hey have fun tonight we appreciate your
time as always Jeff thank you anytime
Jeff Van Gundy for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]